As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, dear brothers and sisters. As
we watch what is unfolding today in
Gaza, we have to understand that
opposition is counting on us to lose
attention, to become fatigued, and to
move on with the new cycle. And just as
we can't allow them to dictate our
attention, we also can't allow them to
dictate the pace of our solidarity. And
part of that solidarity is going to be
there to rebuild Gaza, short-term,
long-term. I am proud to give my
support, my word of support to trusted
brothers and sisters in the United
Kingdom that have started a waqf, that
have started an endowment to make sure,
inshallah ta'ala, that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be
long-term, and we will not forget our
cause in Palestine. We will not forget
the cause of Al-Aqsa, and we will not
forget, bidhnillah ta'ala, our brothers
and sisters in Gaza. Jazakum Allahu
khairan. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. Ronaldo, before taking a
penalty kick, says
the following words,
Bismillah.
In the name of Allah.
I mean, let's be honest here, guys. If a
Muslim comes and says, "In the name of
Jesus," it can leave him, take him out
of the fold of Islam. So, to me here,
and I'll be honest with you, I know a
brother whose uh brother, his the
brother that I know, his own blood
brother, uh works with Ronaldo
carefully. And we've spoken to him, and
it might be true. It might be true that
he is already a Muslim, uh subhanallah.
But yes, so I'm going to leave that
inshallah, but let's watch the video,
inshallah. Before he takes the penalty
kick, let's look like carefully of what
Ronaldo is saying, and why is he saying
this? Because the word Bismillah,
brothers and sisters, is what our lives
should encompass, whatever
we are doing.
So, there you go. I mean, that was cool,
because there was a very close camera uh
around his face, subhanallah. And he
could have said anything. He could have
done the cross.
He could have He could have said
anything, you know,
uh you know, just whatever.
He uses the word Bismillah. Meaning he's
been taught, if not seen people around
him saying the word Bismillah.
Bismillah, brothers and sisters, is
something that we start our day with,
everything from eating to intimacy with
your partner, to whatever you do,
entering the car, leaving the car, in
the name of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So much so, the hadith of the Prophet
Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam said, "If you
have a place that aches, you know, you
say, 'Bismillah, Bismillah, Bismillah.'"
Ustadh Omar Suleiman, Sheikh Omar
Suleiman has a beautiful video, uh which
you guys can watch, inshallah, about
Bismillah. Brothers and sisters, and
scholars have written books
on the Bismillah, brothers and sisters.
And we say it in our morning and evening
adhkar, which is very important for you
guys to protect from evil eye, jealousy,
envy, uh from physical and uh spiritual
harm, which we have on our Salah Pro
app. It's download, it's for free. We're
a charity. The the the app belongs to
the ummah. It's uh free, no ads, no
subscriptions, nothing, inshallah. And
in the morning, I usually what I say,
In the name of Allah, by by whose name
nothing can harm
or uh harm nor in the heavens, and He is
the all-hearing, the all-knowing. The
Prophet Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam said,
"Anyone that says this in the morning
and evening, brothers and sisters," the
adhkar is quite uh There's more than
that. "Will be protected, subhanallah,
unless what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
decrees." So, brothers and sisters, make
dua for him, inshallah. It is good news.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala guide him
to Islam. And for you guys to make the
most out of this, if someone Look, he
can be a Muslim or not. Use this
Bismillah. It is something that we
should do in our day and put barakah and
blessings in it, inshallah. So,
Bismillah, brothers and sisters, may
Allah bless and preserve you guys. Do
not forget to subscribe to our new
channel, Let's Play a Game, for amazing
guests and speakers around the world. We
had Muhammad Hijab on our fourth
episode. Subhanallah, brothers and
sisters, and we've got more more amazing
guests lined up. Go and subscribe to
Let's Play a Game, and watch the full
podcast, inshallah. It's a game show,
one of its kind in the Muslim world,
inshallah. Till next time. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.